I wanted to dig into the motivation for
once yeah so I have some friends very
very smart very accomplished who either
didn't ever go to college or dropped out
of college and some of them for some of
them going back and getting the diploma
was just a and this is not a bad
motivation at all but they had carried
some type of like defensiveness and
insecurity about having not gone to
college and finished was that any piece
of it oh I was planning on becoming a
physician a doctor emergency room doctor
or something like my dad and so I or go
to business school or go to some I
always planned on having a very at least
getting a college degree and so I think
there's an element of of wanting to kind
of keep learning more keep doing more
not for the sake of getting the degree
but for the sake of being in an
environment where I can keep expanding
my horizons and I think the thing is
like I and I I have that through my job
as well there's so many ways that I'm
able to learn just by traveling and
meeting people and and I and I feel like
everybody has that it's not just I mean
I am a unique situation I get to travel
to crazy places but but I think just
it's kind of a mindset a mentality a
perspective of just keeping your eyes
and ears open do you have any favorite
classes or professors besides the coding
anything come to mind
I took a feminism class at NYU which was
really fascinating for understanding the
different the history the history of
feminism academic perspectives the
different waves of feminism a lot of a
lot of academic reading around the topic
beyond just kind of rah-rah girl power
you